[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 22nd
episode of my chest trap series in this
episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful high profile trap in chigorin
defense from the black perspective the
opening arises after the falling water d
4 d phi c 4 and now the characteristic
chigorin defense move Knight to c6 here
it doesn't matter whether your opponent
continues with Knight to c3 or the move
Knight to f3 let's say in this game
Knight to c3 happening and after Knight
to f6 and Knight to f3 released to the
critical position of this line here my
recommendation is you should certainly
capture on c4 and enter into the
mainline the old move in this position
is defy however in the recent time this
move doesn't score well the simple
reason is after Knight to e5 black is
hanging on to the c4 pawn and I have
attached a recent model game of Indian
rising star pregnant ah where he crushed
his opponent in 32 mows so kindly check
it out probably that's why in the recent
era white is mainly focusing on the
movie 4 which in fact very logical
grabbing the space in the center as well
as trying to regain the pawn ok no
problem
black continues with Bishop to g4 so
putting down the knight and threatening
Bishop captures f3 and then Knight
captures d4 something white needs to pay
attention immediately so the main line
continues with Bishop to e3 protecting
on d4 black plays a 6 and after why to
regain the pawn with Bishop capture c4
black pin down another night with Bishop
to b4 and this is something I like about
sugar in defense
unlike other black openings chigorin is
very
active and aggressive opening as you can
see Black has already created a threat
on capturing on e4 so accordingly white
has tried to move Queen to c2 or Queen
to d3 in this episode we are going to
concentrate on the modern move Queen to
d3 however if you opponent continues
with Queen to c2 then I have attached a
sample line in the PGN which will give
you a very good idea how to play such a
position
Queen to d3 and black plays this tricky
move push up to h5 and the trap is set
right here now as per the online
database 70% of the games continues with
the MU a 3 which I personally found a
great inaccuracy in this line as well
should have castle first nevertheless we
should see what happens after the move
a3 has white straightaway fallen into
our trap
and the line goes as follows black first
capture on c3 pawn captures c3 and now
comes this Bishop to g6 attacking twice
on e4 and at first sight it doesn't
seems like white is having any trouble
as white can easily defend that pawn
with either of this to move but in fact
it's an illusion as in all the lines
black is going to get upon so let's see
each reply by turn and find out what's
wrong in that the first move I want to
consider is Bishop to g5 pinning down
the knight and thus saving the pawn but
in fact black indeed can capture on e4
well if Queen moves then after Bishop to
defy black is a healthy pawn up so
that's not a solution and the critical
line goes as follows
Bishop captures up six counter attacking
the Queen Bishop captures d3 Bishop
captures d8 Bishop captures c4 so
regaining the piece back and after
Bishop capture c7 yes indeed the
material balance has been restored but
look at the white first thing he cannot
castle on the Kings side and this
backwards c3 pawn is a clear-cut target
in the middle game just to illustrate my
point I like to show you a game between
two 2,200 rated opponent where black
continues with rook to ch attacking the
bishop bishop to f4 now black target the
c3 with Knight to e7 so idea is very
simple Knight wants to go into the d5
square and attack on c3 and white
decided to meet this with counter
attacking move Knight to d2 okay Knight
to defy indeed happen on the board so as
you can see black is attacking to sport
so white responds his force what has to
play Bishop to e5 counter attacking on
g7 but after the following sequence that
is f6 attacking the bishop bishop to g3
Knight captures c3 rook to Sivan
probably this is what white is hoping
but after Bishop to d3 black managed to
save his piece and in fact 1upon in a
broad daylight the second move Knight to
d2 is more natural in this position as
it is protecting the e4 and if it's
required then white can also play the
move tree and what can be the wrong in
this move
well of course everything looks so good
except one problem that black has this
little reply
so black says sweetie sorry but you
cannot save your pawn Knight captures
efore what else challenging blacks idea
and here comes the whole point behind
sacrificing the piece black has this
magical moon Queen to h4 so not only
attacking twice on e4 Knight but that
poor pawn on f2 is pinned down and that
means white can no longer defend on e4
one high-profile game here continues
with castle on the Kings side but after
Queen captures efore once again black
emerge with an extra pawn and in fact
did manage to win at the end kindly
check out rest of the game in the PGN
which will give you a very good idea how
to convert your extra advantage that's
it guys I hope you enjoyed on this
wonderful trappy line in the main line
checker in defense into now and practice
if you reach this position remember play
the move Bishop to h5 allow your
opponent to play a3 and after the
following sequence we have the star move
Bishop to g6 which wins the pawn on 11th
more of the game and after that with
accurate play you can get some great
victories thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care